well let me ask you for some advice
you've been through one heck of a career
one heck of a life what advice would you
give to a young person today
well in wrestling i i i think wrestling
is really a microcosm of what your
life's going to be and that's why one of
the things that i stress to kids is like
if we can go through this now and you
figure i i've couple kids who are
struggling with certain things around if
you can figure out this now in wrestling
to make a lot better figure out now and
get over this mental hump then when
you're 32 and you have two kids and
right and your job's not going well it's
gonna be a lot worse could be a lot more
painful then let's let's [ __ ] figure
it out now so a lot of these things a
lot of these lessons we can learn from
wrestling whether it's persistence or
perseverance or work ethic or you know i
said wrestlers show up on time and they
work hard right these things if we can
learn these things at an early age those
are general those characteristics
characteristics will generally carry on
throughout our life and those are the
things that are going to make us really
successful so um
you know i would say find a great coach
someone who's gonna spend a lot of time
and put a lot of time into you and make
sure they have a lot of wisdom and steal
all the wisdom that you can from them
and then though if you can be successful
at one thing generally whatever that
recipe was that took you to be
successful with that apply to everything
else
right apply to the rest of your life
apply it to
getting a wife that you enjoy
apply it to
living in a place you want to live doing
a job you want to do right there's so
many possibilities and you just have to
be bold enough to go take those chances
it's interesting because like early on
in life is when you have much more time
like people don't realize this time to
learn the lessons
like
somehow later in life
you get busier responsibilities and all
that kind of stuff like high school is a
magical time in college college yeah
yeah there's so much time
right learn but you don't even have kids
yet yeah i don't have kids that still
fills up well no i on purpose and i did
something that many people don't seem to
be able to do i walked away from a lot
of responsibilities just
by saying goodbye oh okay but like but
you know meetings like there's everybody
around me at mit was like
meetings fill the day and then you have
more projects and you do a great job and
you become successful and then the more
meetings fill the day and more
responsibilities as opposed to like wait
a minute do i want to be involved in all
these things
uh and
instead do i want to
find one or two things to really focus
on and
that's what i choose but like yeah that
becomes harder and harder and harder to
get older you know what i mean i'm sure
and and also the more success you have
you become sought after other places
yeah too i'm sure that's happening with
you and it's hard to say keep saying no
no no
it's hard yeah
you